on avait fait un documentaire ya pas
très longtemps avec son fils tom et via
un amour aussi toute la famille c'est
vraiment débat voilà est qui qui perd
son papa d'une maladie que je connais
bien il est très jeune pour perdre son
papa de cette maladie donc oui ça me
parle aussi parce que voilà j'avais
perdu quelques ma mère a au même âge
j'ai donc été très touché par lui et
puis et puis très touché et très
choqué parce que je ne savais pas qu'il
avait pas bien depuis quelques jours et
comme j'avais une atelier à côté de moi
il ya quelques semaines et qu'elle
m'avait dit j'ai une bonne nouvelle à
t'annoncer il ya plus de métastases sur
le deuxième poumon ça va mieux
trois semaines après j'allume la télé je
je je vois ça morges cc 1 c'est un choc
gigantesque alors regardez tous les
gîtes et bien sûr toutes les chaînes ont
annoncé la disparition de notre jean
pierre d'amours regarde on vient de
l'apprendre la mort de jean pierre
pernaut l'ancien présentateur du jt de
tf1 il est que ce présentateur du 13
heures de tf1 s'est éteint à l'âge de 71
ans présentateur aussi on s'en souvient
tous de la célèbre émission combien ça
coûte qui nous a accompagnés pendant des
années des années pendant des dizaines
d'années effectivement tous les jours il
a accompagné tous les français cela 13h
alors on aura beaucoup plusieurs
intervenants acquis 20 ans nous de
parler d'eux le chant pierre pernaut
voilà vous le savez on l'a appris à
quelques minutes 1 donc on va être
vraiment dans des conditions voilà deux
directs extrêmement ce soir puisque il y
aura des gens qui m'ont succédé on va
raconter des anecdotes sur jean-pierre
et ce soir je veux aussi qu'on sourit
parce que jean-pierre on a rigolé avec
lui pendant des années et des années
c'était vraiment un très proche jeu il
le sait je l'aimé énormément et même si
c'est vrai que au moment de la guerre
entre tf1 et nous c'était le sol qui
disait rifains j'irai chez cyril quoi
qu'il arrive voilà il venait nous voir
tout le temps il m'a s'est en outre les
ordres de tf1 et des deux de ddd du
directeur de tf1 il dise et quoi qu'il
arrive j'irai chez mon ami et c'est vrai
qu'ils venaient nous voir tout le temps
c'était le solde qui faisaient ça valait
rien ouais hein moi je suis très ému
il est à votre mariage en plus on est
donc j'ai une pensée pour nathalie que
j'aime très fort
et ils avaient peur de personne jean
pierre pernaut absolument personne moi
je me souviens à l'époque de matois
flavie présentait une émission ça le
football moi plus mon ex mari qu'il
produit qui produisait cette émission
cité pour le mondial de foot de 2002 et
jean pierre était le seul à pouvoir
s'opposer à etienne mougeotte qui était
le grand grand matures ou de tf1 et
personne n'osait dire avec des notes je
ne suis pas d'accord et on fera comme je
veux et lui faisait comme ils voulaient
effectivement votre anecdote que vous
disiez lorsque vous étiez un peu plus en
guerre avec tf1 et que personne n'osait
venir de tf1 lui peu importe voilà
d'abord au delà du fait qu'il était une
star c'était aussi un caractère mais ce
caractère là personne ne pouvait lui d
une fidélité incroyable fidélité
incroyable jean pierre diot vous avez
fait un documentaire d'ailleurs nos
documentaires on les verra d'ailleurs ce
soir 1 / s'est vite c'est vrai que
j'étais très proche de la de la famille
et les gens mais on a tourné beaucoup
avec eux c'était malgré le fait que
c'était une légende de la télévision
c'était quelqu'un d'extrêmement simple
et on l'a suivi partout dans son
quotidien chez lui au marché à
disneyland avec lui et moi j'ai toujours
été étonné par la simplicité de jean
pierre perez qui a prêté des très
proches des gens il refusait jamais une
photo osée des centaines et des
centaines de photos il s'intéressait
vraiment aux gens ce qui est très rare
dans le monde de la télévision c'est
vrai des gens qui sont très proches des
gens qui s'intéressent aux gens alors j
il était vraiment le même dans la vie et
à l'antenne alors que des voitures me
racontent leur entrée sur le plateau de
thaler c'est vrai que le public a appris
la nouvelle également et on a senti
vraiment le public très très affecté
aussi un par la disparition de deux jean
pierre pernaut il ya une ambiance un peu
spécial sur le plateau ce soir parce que
c'est vrai que 32 ans et puis on le
considérait tous comme quelqu'un de
sunny men tous les français qui
n'avaient jamais ils n'ont jamais eu la
chance de le rencontrer en vrai et et
nous aussi c'est vraiment joli quelqu'un
qu'on aimait énormément c'est y faisait
partie de la famille tpm paix même s'il
était dans le groupe tf1 gille c'était
une icône est une icône à la fois qu'on
admirait mais qui étaient tellement
proches tellement accessible que ça fait
je trouve ça crée un immense choc moi je
voudrais raconter une anecdote à un peu
gay souvent
nathalie on échange beaucoup pour parler
des sujets avoir des infos vous feriez
vous aimait l'appeler fatou des
jeux la peine je l'appelle souvent et
puis en échange et donc on se donne des
infos etc et chaque fois que je
l'appelais notamment ces dernières
semaines elle disait attends attends
attends là c'est un peu compliqué je
vais faire venir jean pierre et donc
elle faisait venir jean pierre à côté
alors hier jean pierre qui parlait le
dit attends ce ballet haut parleur il
parle et puis c'était une info sur sur
jacques legros et f1 à l'orateur a dit
on va demander à jean pierre et jean
pierre disait oui je te confirme il a
signé un contrat etc et nathalie d asi
jean-pierre confirme tu peux y aller
mongil et donc hier jean-pierre kiriya
côté ai dit tu vois il s'était donné une
info voilà voilà vous venez de foot note
nathalie dans la merde c'est sympa
commerciaux grossi non mais c'est sympa
vous avez globalisé n'hésitez pas à
continuer continuer benjamin vous étiez
pendant des années sur sur tf1 c'était
le taulier jean-pierre ans et oui mais
surtout moi ce qui m'a marqué c'est que
vous aimez quand on commence la
télévision et qu'on rencontre des baies
personne et je continue et ce avec
drucker et avec lui on rencontre la
télévision voilà mais même quand on est
animateur ya jean pierre foucault aussi
brasser les voilà c'est fait et c'est
vrai que quand on le voit pour la
première fois il ya un temps pour se
dire merde merde cc pernaut passer le
taux que j'ai vu pendant des années peut
tirer des visions et après j'ai eu la
chance de le côtoyer parce que flavie
présenter une quotidienne sur le capot
d'une coupe du monde en 2002 or en corée
et c'est vrai que j'ai vu le bleu bleu
la personne travailler et comme la
france a perdu très vite qu'il fallait
tout changer c'était un mec incroyable
dans le dans le travail et dans la
capacité à tous bouleversés sens si on
résume en fait jean pierre pernaut il
est ami avec tout vos ex
mari
et femme est ce que tu es incroyable
c'était sa capacité à tout changer et je
front et paie pas de prompteur et
commerçants commun avec vous
effectivement c'est peut-être que vous
c'était une catastrophe un prof pour tf1
que le la france perdent également
rapidement parce qu'ils avaient misé sur
cette émission on sait que tout
s'arrêterait longtemps les audiences etc
et lui avait réussi à bouleverser les
conducteurs à tout casser pour tenir
quand même le public et le public était
resté présent malgré tout alors que la
france ne jouait plus et alors maman
etienne mougeotte lance l'ancien patron
de tf1 c'était un immense patron a
vraiment été le ponte un ponte de la
télévision disait souvent jean pierre
pernaut quand il te regarde dans la
caméra tu ne peux plus la chine le poste
peut plus lâcher la chaîne et série qui
dit qu'il avait un regard qui faisait
que tu étais obligé de regarder et qui
il arrivait intéresser tout par son
regard et c'est vrai que jean pire moi
c'est pour ça qu'on s'entendait très
bien jean pierre et moi parce que c'est
vrai que l'on disait souvent voilà moi
c'est un peu un modèle pour moi
jean-pierre même si il était journaliste
voilà - dans le divertissement mais
c'est vrai que c'est quelqu'un voilà qui
qui faisait en fait ce qu'il avait dans
la tête à l'instinct à l'instar et il
était pas vraiment comme les autres
présentateurs de jt sur leur scooter
alors bernad voilà il est il rappelé
maintenant qu'ils sont dans sa veine un
oui et c'est y voilà bruce toussaint je
le vois qui est excellent brucy ils
essayent de voilà de faire aussi
d'amener une petite patte voilà il y en
a plein derrière qui sont dit nous on va
être une écriture à la r on va être un
petit peu comme jean pierre pernaut
bernard vous avez dû l'annoncer dans le
6 à 7 et un instant je sais que vous le
connaissiez très bien jean pierre joue
vous êtes très très ému de cette
nouvelle oui c'était très difficile de
démarrer une émission comme ça moi je
les ai connus si vous voulez dans une
autre vie il ya très très longtemps il
ya plus de 25 ans chez des amis communs
et je suis rentré ensuite à tf1 et il a
toujours été extrêmement gentil avec moi
moi même impressionné de rencontrer cet
homme cet ami des français il incarnait
pour moi elle incarne toujours la france
la france qu'on aime la france 2 je
viens d'ailleurs la france des gens
modestes à l'époque en tout cas pour ça
c'était comme ça et c'était c'était pour
moi bouleversant à chaque fois de le
voir de par sa gentillesse vous vous
dites c'est une superstar il est vrai
qu'il est gentil et te salue et vous
accompagne et est toujours un mot gentil
et il vous appelle et vous dis ça parce
que tu as fait et c'est bon bref et même
quand j'ai eu des soucis avec tf1 il m'a
appelé en me disant je te soutiens et
j'étais j'en avais besoin de ce soutien
là ce moment là et puis nathalie qui est
une amie aussi je veux dire c'est je
suis désolé tout à l'heure j'ai je
venais de l'apprendre et c'était c'est
terrible pour moi c'est inacceptable
oui pas parti en plus on a tourné il ya
pas longtemps ensemble une émission mais
j'avais appelé je vais dit tu sais si
t'es pas bien tu viens pas c'est pour
animaux
ce qu'il adore les animaux donc je
préparais les missions et juge appelle
nathalie et lui jeudi six sites est pas
en forme je ne viens pas assez pas grave
mais dit non j'étais promis de faire
l'émission il a fait une émission où il
était très bien en pleine forme quelques
problèmes de respiration tout de même
souriant et l'émission était très très
joyeuse et c'était jeu j'ai du mal à
parler franchement j'ai du mal bernard
en plus ce qu'on voit c'est que bernard
séris qu'on le connaît il a il il est
très fort et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'il a pas fait une carrière bondée il
a fait une grande carrière chez les
verts mais là il a eu la franchise de
dire plein de choses il n'y certaine
hypocrisie dans le métier et on sent que
jean-pierre il était vraiment à pas jean
perret disaient ce qu'ils pensent et si
vous voulez voir quelqu'un et le voyez
si vous voulez pas voir une autre
personne ise il était également fort est
tellement excellent en tant que
journaliste et ses audiences étaient
tellement énorme qui pourrait être un
peu faire ce qu'il voulait c'était un
des seuls en télévision on voit
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que c'est voilà
ce terrain des seuls qui pouvaient faire
ce qu'ils voulaient et dire mériaudeau
patron de tf1 pour dire voilà je vais
voir un ami et c'est vrai que vous
voulez vous avez un regard très aiguisé
sur la télévision vous avez vu plein de
faux des points à chaque fois vous êtes
d'une franchise incroyable et c'est vrai
que jean-pierre on sent vraiment c'est
quelqu'un à part c'était la liberté ils
disaient ce qu'ils voulaient quand ils
voulaient ils étaient marginales toute
façon été très marginale ils se mêler de
rien les réunions il y allait pas toutes
façons il avait son journal son jt qui
l'a imposé quand il a commencé à faire
le journal de des régions personne n'en
voulait on
lui tomber dessus on se moquer de lui et
tout lui ai rien à [ __ ] il a dit je
vais le faire il a imposé sa de parler
des régions de parler des français de la
france profonde et ça au début c'était
pas très bien vu et il a imposé son truc
et il est ce qu'il est c'est-à-dire cet
homme que tous les français aiment et
que tous les français doivent pleurer
maintenant